[Musique]
rouler vers le ciel oval inde 1ère fille
bihan vous pensiez connaître les
voitures volantes qu'entreprise ps
perspective nous réserve encore mieux le
voyage dans l'espace
cette start up spécialisée dans le
tourisme spatial vient de dévoiler sa
capsule à mi chemin entre le dirigeable
et la montgolfière qui vous emmènera à
30 km d'altitude
une capsule tout confort avec vue 360°
champagne et wifi à bord et pour
profiter de ce voyage luxueux de 6h à
débourser 125 mille dollars c'est le
prix du billet tout seul et le premier
vol prévu en 2024 et déjà complet ça
vous laisse le temps d'économiser un peu
d'ici là
[Musique]
ça fait cent seize mille euros vous si
vous l'avez voilà vous avez pris votre
billet
mais c'est pas possible ça non mais je
vais vous dire la vérité d'hier est ou
pas en vrai de quoi
j'ai pas peur en avion une pote
conneries l'avion non mais prendre un
petit des gens de tout le temps l'avion
s'est pas me laisser y aller en avion ou
un mais non tu dois y aller en fait tu
t'y bancal et je crois
qu'ils n'ont qu'à les chamois alors été
en parlant de la calèche il ya toujours
aussi le bag avec ta meuf qui veut faire
la qualif et ça
j'ai toujours rêvé de calais c'est que
ma mère je vous jure que c'est vrai je
kiffe quand je vois des amoureux
j'aurais passé et sim en calèche et
genre mais il parle toujours une langue
que tu connais j'ai refusé de faire
profil
bas et j'ai toujours rêvé de faire de la
calèche est comme neuf mais qu'est ce
qui est dommage l'argent
mais jamais ma main c'est pas eu les
'lionnes' ch 2 propose un je ne sais
même pas pour un canard ah ouais bah oui
c'est pour ça mais voilà fléchissent et
rolfo vous laisser aller
après tout mais pas ça parce que moi et
elles se nichent tu vois tu vas là
quelle est
l'origine de votre image de garçon un
peu c'est quoi c'est pas bon tu vois toi
si tu pouvais je laisserais castaldi qui
garde la cage non non non pas du lait
cil toiture et vous [ __ ] c'est dommage
je sais je sais
qu'avant si vous avez une folie à faire
toi à part bouffer un q
ha bon créneau mais ceux récoltés
voilà une folie non pas non acheter une
île une île flottante
c'est le pâtissier toi non mon rêve
m'aiderait mois grâce absolue acheta une
petite île mais ne pas pas une grande
île une toute petite mais voilà il
déserte et j'ai tout à la wii fit ou
l'électricité tout ça va tout seul mais
jouer avec que les gens les gens que
j'aime les gens que j'invite mes avoir
ma petite île à moi quoi tu payes les
gens ait envie tout
ça serait génial vivre à l'hôtel oui
elle est ce que tu t'en fous et a pas
besoin
d'une formule 1
je verrai la conseil d'ami pas c'était
mon poto
qu'elle les chênes verts va aller
batailler famille lieux sous les mers
j'attends mon tour
attend attend pas oui c'est oui bonsoir
ça ne nous a pas une goutte oit le
tourcoing pourquoi ça dort lille roubaix
tourcoing embrasse tous les lillois tous
les roubaisiens tous les êtres simonini
s'embrassent qu'est-ce que tu précision
dino restaurant le jules verne a plus on
monte en haut de la tour eiffel et après
on fait monter sur la tour est un
scénario
malin oui mais c'est pas sauter les deux
premières c
[Rires]
est que tu avais tu la mets une petite
faune tour eiffel en profiter ça suffit
ça passe quand même ils sont éco les
déchets ce qui vaut aux jo-2006 et une
folie comme ça c'est une robe de mariée
tout en bijoux pour faire
[Applaudissements]
mécanique au cas
où mais
je vois pas ta en train de tout tout
tout arrête arrête
arrête donc que tu as foot avec une robe
rouge
une race hahahaha c'est un jour je me
marie c'est que ta meuf il ya toujours
des meufs elle arrive au début du
mariage ils sont hyper chauffe
réellement la robe de mariée est au bout
de la soirée je suis né voit efira la
meuf qui n'eut à la fin du mariage r je
divorce
james et noir est de la fal arrive à des
flèches au talon je suis là mois après
la vague d'attentats par les pieds nus
avec la route qui descend
ne connaît non avec l'équipe avec l'ailé
les écoles ambitieux
mais son échec
mais cela c'est pas la soirée sur des
talons de 12 mais mal et chantepie
mocassins itanium
je suis bien dans mon coeur et je le
souhaite sans déconner on ya toujours
les meufs quand elle se marie au bout
d'un moment elle s'est tenue dans le
mariage oui l'attenté comme à ses mixes
et
6 et
affamés c'est relou bâlois seront le
terreau longue série vous avez un
problème avec les pieds nus je n'ai pas
laissé plus c'est que tu es même pour
vis-à-vis des gens oui c'est important
dès qu ils ont déroulé j'ai vu là
reflétant pièce montée là c'est mon cas
ça devienne crêpes arrêté non mais ça je
ne suis pas mal je parle de supporter
bien raison non mais c'est vrai oui
cinéma on a quitté gens
de contraindre fmcs ou travel et ce
serait bien non alors les robes de
mariée avec les baskets ce que chacun
aurait accrochage on s'en est seul sur
un support comme un support datant
supporters non mais ce que moi je change
de fut donc
non non non